on l'annonçait depuis des années et
c'est maintenant chose faite pour la
première fois dans l'histoire canadienne
le nombre de citoyens âgés dépasse le
nombre de jeunes de moins de 14 ans est
évident qu on est dans une ère de
vieillissement dans les pays occidentaux
et la planète entière est dans une ère
de vieillissement et que ce que l'on
constate au canada pour le 1er juillet
de cette année c'est ce qui va se
constater partout dans le monde en 2015
donc 5,1 pour cent des canadiens sont
âgées de plus de 65 ans et seulement 16
% ont moins de 14 ans si cette tendance
se poursuit en 2024
l'écart entre les deux groupes sera
encore plus prononcée à noter que c'est
au québec et dans les maritimes qu'on
retrouve la plus forte proportion de
gens âgés tout particulièrement au
nouveau brunswick le phénomène qui
créent de plus en plus aux déséquilibres
économiques et fiscales entre l'est et
l'ouest du pays
ce que l'on risque c'est ce que moi
j'appelle une société à deux vitesses où
dans l'est on va trimé dur pour garder
les services publics que l'on connaît
alors que dans l'oise ce sera plus
facile de maintenir le statu quo donc il
faut une réponse fédérale cette chose là
et ça devrait être un enjeu de la
campagne électorale en plus du phénomène
de vieillissement
le canada a connu un ralentissement de
la croissance de sa population en 2014
2015 par rapport à l'année précédente
cette situation est évidemment liée à la
baisse de la natalité et on ne peut la
compenser qu en accueillant plus
d'immigrants au pays
comme les allemands le font en ce moment
avec la vague d'immigration syrienne
pense cet expert
cette rentrée massive celle ci accepte
entre guillemets partout les couches de
la société avec une décroissance de la
population qui peut être que néfaste
pour un pays comme l'allemagne
dans son dernier bilan statistique
canada observe également que le canada a
reçu 28 1000 immigrants de moins que
l'année précédente
mais selon des experts il ne s'agit pas
d'une baisse vraiment significative ici
normal grondin radio canada montréal